and back to virginia where glenn younkin
is close to an incredible victory
tonight something that really none of
the so-called experts really thought he
could pull off but mcauliffe's campaign
may not go down without a fight one aide
telling fox there is substantial amount
of early vote left to be counted along
with large numbers of from places like
fairfax richmond and other urban areas
where we have outperformed the rest of
the state and just days ago we learned
mcauliffe hired notorious democrat
election fixer mark elias who will no
doubt be leading any efforts to fight
the results joining me now is harmee
dillon attorney rnc national committee
woman from california who lived for a
long time in virginia and jill vogel
republican
election uh lawyer helping the yunken
team um let's go to you first harmeet
harmeet you and i attended uva together
in law school and back then
charlottesville was kind of a you know
it was it was kind of a
middle-of-the-road place just some
liberalism but
did you expect what you're seeing
tonight with this groundswell and the
mcauliffe party is seems to have been a
little bit
disbanded by the way but this is yonkin
headquarters harmeet your
take uh laura this is absolutely
earth-shattering when you and i were at
uva together doug wilder democrat
moderate democrat was the governor and
that's what democrats were like in
virginia fast forward to today where
terry mcauliffe has been embracing the
most extreme radical left agenda and
policies and doing so with the arrogance
of somebody who won the
governor's seat before and it completely
failed and so i think this is a wake-up
call for democrats all over the country
and in fact kamala harris said that very
thing but this is not an accident this
victory is the result of the hard
preparation and groundwork by lawyers
like jill by the republican national
lawyers association which trained and
deployed
almost 100 lawyers into the field and by
the rnc which invested heavily in over
100 staff so this is not just sort of
the glamor of personality and flashy you
know results like that it is about the
hard hard work in the trenches scott
pressler
making sure to to register voters that's
how you do it you don't do it with
personality you do it with latching on
to the policies that move middle america
move the soccer moms and that's the kids
and that's the schools and that's the
taxes and that's people paying a hundred
dollars to fill up their cars those are
the things that won this election and uh
interesting tweet earlier tonight which
i kept meaning to get to about you know
some of the other historic uh
firsts there will be tonight the
democrats are always talking about first
and we have the first female i believe
is it the attorney general of virginia
who
has an incredible story of her own and
and we're going to go to now the younkin
team jill vogel uh who's representing
the yunkan team tonight on the show any
outstanding legal challenges that you
expect from mcauliffe and mark elias
jill
hey laura well at this point it's too
soon to tell
i will tell you it was an interesting
message that tara mcauliffe telegraphed
to everybody tonight when he did not
concede
i think it's pretty clear to the rest of
america where virginia is virginia gave
america a resounding message that we've
got a new virginia what a difference a
day makes
um and i would just also add laura that
is our lieutenant governor yeah sorry
about that
elected tonight that's okay winston
sears who is the first female and i say
that because i actually was a statewide
candidate four years ago for lieutenant
governor so um i just want to give a
shout out to winston and congratulate
her but well um anyway it's too soon to
tell but i can tell you
yeah go ahead
now go now go ahead
i was
i was just going to say um i'm super
proud of the
campaign that our candidates ran but i
also want to say um to to your question
the the legal support that we had both
from volunteers and from lawyers around
the commonwealth of virginia we put
together something that has never ever
been done in the commonwealth of
virginia with thousands of volunteers
and hundreds of lawyers and we also had
something that's never happened in
virginia and that is an election that
started on september 17th that was
really the beginning of our election day
and election day didn't end until
tonight at 7 pm so we had 45 days of an
election day and the most important
thing that we could do was build out a
structure to give our people the
confidence to vote early and know that
we were paying attention and that their
vote would be counted
this campaign i i said it last night
when i was in leesburg one of the best
run campaigns and i've been i've been
sadly sadly in the washington area for
like 30 years okay i'm really dating
myself but it is one of the best run
campaigns i have seen of all the
campaigns i've seen
and jilled the entire team was
i mean i i can't really say anything
that you you you guys didn't do right
and that's not being very critical but i
just that's just my honest assessment of
how things weren't uh went i i want to
just read the tweet that i botched
before forgive me shouldn't the media be
all over a black woman who emigrated
from jamaica served in the marines has a
master's degree ran a homeless shelter
for women raised three kids and is now
running to be the highest ranking
minority woman government official in
virginia history
win some sears
again
and uh and we have a cuban uh
uh an individual of cuban descent who
will be uh if things go the way we think
they will uh attorney general of the
state um which is just
incredible
i mean it's this the story the story is
just amazing harmeet
uh closing thoughts here uh all those
moderate republicans uh moderate
democrats across the country what should
they take from this very quickly
uh they should take that the democratic
party is too extreme they are way beyond
the mainstream and that when it comes to
the issues that matter in the pocketbook
and in their families the republican
candidates are their only choice and no
amount of hiring mark elias or other
extremists like that is going to change
that truth
all right harmeet and jill thanks so
much and glenn younkin is going to take
the stage any moment fox news is told by
someone close to the campaign we're
going to celebrate tonight the mcauliffe
campaign
celebration seems to have dissipated
according to my sources there so
i don't think they're getting ready to
celebrate much over there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else